what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today the official trailer for creed
press I am excited for this Michael B
Jordan himself is directing this film
which I think is really cool you know
Sylvester Stallone he ended up directing
like four of the Rocky movies right two
three four rugby yeah yeah you're ready
like four of the Rocky movies it's only
a matter of time before Michael B Jordan
Donna's Creed himself ends up directing
one of these films and uh I I haven't
seen a frame of this yet but I'm like I
feel I feel like he'll do a good job I'm
a big fan of the rocky franchise
um the the totality of it all and I just
learned that apparently a couple years
ago they announced that they would be
doing some other Rocky film as well like
not a Creed movie it's another Rocky
movie but I I don't know that's still
gonna happen they're all supposed to do
a rocky prequel series but do we really
need that what does it matter we're
gonna watch the Creed 3 trailer let's
get to it
[Music]
be sure to leave a like
the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca Bianca Rocky
my dad
built on their shoulders
hey my man can I help you let me get
autograph there he is no autographs get
off my car you don't remember me huh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
who cares what happened with you too I
didn't tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute oh the
two different paths
looks brutal Damien's fighting the world
he's trying to hurt people
I bounce for you you think you mad
trying to spending half your life in a
cell
it's so buff somebody else live your
life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going take it out of the
ring guys Damien was like family
past talking then maybe you just have to
find out Thompson
sometimes I recognize mine I know that
they needed me
yet wow [ __ ] watching a tree
oh you fear
fear they're called a guilt
that girl whatever was and walk into
what is this feels so goddamn personal
[ __ ]
damn it looks awesome
film for IMAX oh that'd be great to
watch on IMAX holy [ __ ] you know I never
I actually didn't finish the movie
Warrior it was just one of those
situations where I was watching it with
somebody and then we had to turn it off
and then I just never picked it back up
but from what I remember of like the 30
to 40 minutes I saw a warrior this kind
of reminds me of that a personal flare
of Brothers who uh who became very
distant and then now it's gonna converge
with them in the ring I like it I mean
obviously there are very different
details here I think it feels very
personal I I really love the direction
they're going with the story when I
first heard Sylvester Stallone wouldn't
be here you know I was like yes
can you do Rocky continue to Rocky
franchise but that's that's just alone
in the movie they didn't really even
think about that until right now at this
very moment what they gave us here at
least I didn't feel like it was it was
necessary like I I had no doubt that
they can continue on the Creed franchise
without Rocky Balboa and it's something
kind of refreshing about having that be
affirmed that okay yeah we don't need
the presence of Rocky right now I'm sure
his presence will live on in some way
they acknowledge Him in the trailer of
course does he need to be in the film I
didn't find myself missing him at least
here in these in these two minutes
because what we're getting just feels so
uh intense and there are aspects of uh
Jonathan Major's Debian of the kind of
that ruthless intensity and having it
out for Adonis Creed the brutality of
him that do remind me of you know Rocky
III's Clubber Lang but definitely
something again feels more personal I
like the story a lot uh that they're at
least setting up them both coming from a
really tough past and then one of them
ended up going in jail while the other
used a legacy name to make a legacy for
himself and then the one who went to
jail felt like he's watching the dream
be fulfilled by somebody else that he
deserves on top of that is forgotten
about you know there's something kind of
effective about when you know Adonis
sees him and he doesn't even remember
him right away or recognize him right
away you know he feels so forgotten
that's also painful like you could feel
there's a lot of pain in Jonathan
Major's performance he's one of those
actors who's really he's a phenomenal
actor like just all around he's a
phenomenal actor but I love are the the
details of the the hints you get of his
performance of when he is talking with
Adonis the very beginning scene that we
have we're leaning on the car or at the
restaurant or when he's talking with him
and Bianca Tess Thompson when he's all
smiles but you could tell there's
there's so much pain underneath those
smiles and this feeling of I've been
betrayed like if you were gonna go have
this successful Journey why'd you
completely forget about me along the way
great way to make something very
effective for giving a primary
motivation for uh Jonathan Majors Damien
but in also giving an internal struggle
here for Michael B Jordan's Donna's
Creed because Adonis you know as they
talk about the trailer the fear and the
guilt and I'm sure that's going to
interfere within the ring itself of not
being able to go all out when he is
fighting because that would interfere
that would be a kind of a blockage for
him to be able to go all out during this
fight there are parts of him that you
know maybe don't feel necessarily
responsible for what happened to him but
feel responsible for the aspects of what
he's being blamed for as well like it's
kind of it's gonna be like a mixed bag
like I think this feels very layered and
and complex I'm excited to see what they
bring to this movie and just the idea of
Michael B Jordan and Jonathan Majors you
know squaring off with each other not
just like physicality wise but acne wise
they're just they're like two Powerhouse
actors and they just killmonger and King
and Valkyrie and what they had to have
seen them pit against each other it just
feels so exciting to me it looks awesome
I'm curious to see you know like Michael
B Jordan's Direction obviously like this
looks confident I'm not enough yet for
for me to really pinpoint like what is
Michael B Jordan doing that is
specifically different I can't quite
tell you know specifically like the
framing wise really it's going to come
out in in the editing as well I feel
like he'll do a good job because like
looking at this trailer it doesn't look
directly looks awesome it looks as
awesome as always I think the last two
Creed movies were directed gray two
different directors and this movie also
looks awesome but I'm really loving
about the imagery so far is how much
they're doing so much of the the
paralleling of their Journeys they are
reflections of one another that Adonis
Creed could have easily gone down the
path that Damien went down and Damien
could have gone down the path Adonis
went down and there's so much of that
reflection Happening Here the alternate
universe where they could have had each
other's past or there's the alternate
universe of hey we could have gone down
this path together I like stories of of
when you have to overcome obstacles of
your past and how the guilt of your past
can can haunt you and then you have to
go through this journey where it's
ultimately about letting go and creating
A New Path forward but yeah guys I
thought this trailer was the [ __ ] I
thought it was awesome Jonathan Majors
is so goddamn buff
ET it's intimidating as hell it's so
scary what did you guys think leave your
thoughts down below please go ahead
subscribe click that Bell leave a like
and uh I'll talk with you all soon thank
you so much for being here
[Music]